turkey's president rajab Tai burdwan
says he's determined to see Russian
grain exported to low-income countries
he's met President Vladimir Putin on the
sidelines of a regional Summit in
Kazakhstan erdogan says he wants to
strengthen the Istanbul agreement so
poor countries get the Grain and
fertilize that they need
the Russian president also proposed
setting up a regional gas Hub in Turkey
we have two correspondents on this story
in a moment we'll hear from Cinema in
Istanbul but first let's speak to
Muhammad Val in Moscow so what exactly
are the Russian proposing when it comes
to a gas hub
uh yes Sami President Putin proposed the
creation of this gas hub for
distribution of Russian gas from Turkey
saying that turkey is a reliable partner
and a partner that has the ability and
the means to do this uh this job and
also turkey has the confidence of both
sides and it is well placed apparently
to to to be this uh go between between
Russia and the European Partners Russia
has been talking about this for some
time as an idea and it seems that it is
well received in Turkey the spokesman of
the Kremlin spokesman Dmitry peskov said
later after putting statements that the
two leaders are okay for an immediate
start on that project and also the two
companies gaspram and gasp from the
Russian and bought us the Turkish
pipeline Corporation have even and begun
to talk about it and they are also ready
to launch such a project it's not clear
if this is going to be a new pipeline
that is going to be constructed no no
details about that yet or is it going to
be channeled through the The Turk stream
which is uh in the in the in the Baltic
Sea that's a that's a Russian Pipeline
that takes gas from from Russia to
Turkey so it's too early to have all
those details but it seems that the two
sides are okay on this idea and they
also said peskov said that they didn't
Russia and Turkey did not consult with
the Europeans about it and it is
something decided only between Tokyo and
Russia
all right thanks so much Muhammad let's
bring in cinema she joins us live from
Istanbul so let's start first of all
Cinema on that issue how are Turkish
officials reacting to Russian
suggestions of a gas Hub in Turkey
well Sami as my colleague also stated a
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
been saying this since yesterday he
spoke at an energy Summit yesterday and
so far we haven't heard anything from
the Turkish officials yet but of course
we don't know what is spoken behind the
closed doors especially for instance
after this press conference two leaders
spoke for one and a half hour turkia is
already an energy
transmitting Center it transfers energy
from east to west and this is one of
turkey's great plans to be a major hub
for Europe and there there are already
pipelines that are transferring uh
different gas and oil from different
companies but of course this is a very
delicate issue for turkey because we are
talking about a new system that is going
to provide rushing gas to the European
countries and the tension between the
west and Russia is on the rise the
Europeans are are desperate for cheaper
energy and person Putin stated that this
can be also a good platform to review
Energy prices which have skyrocketed but
apparently Turks and Russians are
already studying on this matter to see
how it can be handled but definitely
when it comes to energy and energy trade
and the pipelines there are so many
regulations we should also keep in mind
that a turkey should consider possible
sanctions from Europe because of the
current tension that is going on between
the west and Russia so far as I said we
haven't heard anything from the Turkish
officials but definitely they would try
to take benefit of this as long as it it
is in line with a turkey as interest
with the European Union and its
relations with them all right we have
been hearing something though from
Turkish officials when it comes to
Russian fertilizer and grain what
exactly is turkey proposing
uh well summer when the U.N brokered
Ukraine grain deal was signed back in
July in Istanbul
another document was signed with the
Russians separately from ukrainians
which would allow Russian fertilizers
and Grains to be delivered to the world
and since then Turkish president has
been stating that the grains and
fertilizers Russian grains and
fertilizers it should reach the World
Market especially to poorer countries
for instance what erdon said today is
not something new but of course this is
also a good Advantage for Turkish
presidents erdon because the U.N Brokers
Ukraine green deal gave him some
credibility when when it comes to his
relations with the west and those
relations have been strained for a while
as we all know so and this can also
create another chance for Turkish
president to mediate between the west
and Russia again when it comes to grain
fertilizers Also regarding your previous
question let me say that President Putin
who has been stuck with the uh with the
gas exports of his country he's also
trying to give some leverage to the
Turkish president so that he can have
the leverage to mediate between the west
and Russia which can bring Arizona more
credibility
all right thanks so much